c'était attendu c'est désormais officiel
le cio a annoncé le report des jeux
olympiques de tokyo au plus tard pour
l'été 2021 on voit ça avec valentin
carpentier
nous sommes en septembre 2013
les membres de la délégation japonaise
laissent éclater leur joie
tokyo vient de se voir confier l'immense
honneur d'organiser les trente deuxièmes
jeux olympiques modernes plus de six ans
après ce moment historique
la liesse a laissé place à la dure
réalité alors qu'il redoutait une telle
issue le cio n'a pas eu d'autre choix
que de reporter l'événement initialement
prévue du 24 juillet au 9 août 2020 sur
la base de la situation actuelle nous
avons proposé d'envisager de reporter
les jeux olympiques d'environ un an afin
de garantir que les athlètes du monde
entier puissent jouer dans les
meilleures conditions et pour que le
public puisse assister au tournoi en
toute sécurité
j'ai reçu une réponse du président du
cio monsieur bart qui est d'accord à
100% on sort comment il était convenu
que les jeux olympiques et paralympiques
de tokyo aurait lieu au plus tard à
l'été 2000 21 le report désormais acté
le comité international olympique doit
maintenant fixer une nouvelle date
si rien n'a encore été officialisé le
cio annonce que les jeux olympiques de
tokyo auront lieu au plus tard à l'été
2000 21 réticents depuis plusieurs
semaines l'organisation a finalement
cédé sous les nombreuses pressions les
sportifs principaux concernés ont
accueilli avec satisfaction cette
décision world athletics se félicite de
la décision du cio et du gouvernement
japonais de reporter les jeux olympiques
de tokyo 2020 à 2021
c'est ce que veulent les athlètes et
nous pensons que cette décision donnera
à tous les athlètes officiels techniques
et bénévoles un certain répit
une certaine certitude en ces temps sans
précédent est incertain ward rugby
soutient la décision prudente et
nécessaire du comité international
olympique et du comité d'organisation de
tokyo 2020 de reporter les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
le report a donc été privilégié une
solution toujours préférable à une
annulation pure et simple synonyme de
catastrophe économique
même si thomas ce bar président du cio
assure que ce n'est pas une priorité
les conséquences financières n'ont pas
été évoquées et ne sont pas la priorité
il s'agit de protéger des vies c'est une
première pour des jeux olympiques de
l'ère moderne en temps de paix pour
assister à une telle décision
il faut remonter à 1940 une compétition
annulée en raison de la seconde guerre
mondiale la ville qui devait organiser
l'événement tokyo déjà et pour la
nageuse russe yulia efimova elle estime
que le report des jeux l'un des jeux
olympiques est la moins mauvaise des
solutions
j'estime que pour le moment c'est la
solution optimale parce qu'on ne sait
pas comment la situation évoluera dans
les deux ou trois mois à venir
c'est encore pire de tenir tout le monde
en haleine j'ai déjà été dans une
situation similaire il ya quatre ans il
vaut mieux être au courant bien sûr il
est pénible que les jeux olympiques soit
reportée d'un an
surtout pour les athlètes qu'on
qualifiera d'âgés mais il vaut mieux
cela que de mettre en danger sa santé
est resté dans le flou sans comprendre
si on y participera ou non je crois donc
que c'est la meilleure solution dans la
situation actuelle